- Avec tout ce que j'entends
et ce qui se passe ailleurs,
qu'estquququi me garantit
que la qualité de l'air est là
dans Montréal-Est?
- Anne Gauthier demeure à
quelques pas de l'affinerie CCR,
l'dededes 89 entreprises
au Québec qui a le droit
de contrevenir à des normes
environnementales sur les rejets
dans l'air et l'eau, à la suite
d'ententes signées avec
le gouvernement du Québec.
Des papetières, des mines
et des alumineries; certaines
d'entre elles sont situées
dans des milieux urbains.
- Quels sont les contaminants
qui sont émis? Quelles sont
les normes qui ont été fixées?
- Cette avocate spécialisée
en environnement se désole qu'il
soit actuellement impossible
de répondre à ces questions.
ANNE-SOPHIE DORÉ, avocate,
Centre du droit de l'environn.
- Ces informations-là,
notamment sur tout ce qui est
les contaminants émis dans
l'environnement, devraient
être rendues publiques.
C'est quand même assez
préoccupant de voir que
finalement, ça se négocie
un peu à la pièce, la façon
dont certaines industries
peuvent polluer l'environnement.
- À Québec, l'opposition déplore
que la Loi sur la qualité de
l'environnement ne remsesese pas
correctement sa mission.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe, PLQ
- Non, je trouve pas ça normal,
puis je pense surtout qu'il y a
une loi qui é é é passée,
en 2017, qui demandait
plus de transparence.
SOL ZANETTI, député, QS
- S'il y a une leçon qu'on peut
retenir de ce qui s'est passé
à Rouyn-Noranda, c'est vraiment
qu'on ne peut pas faire
confiance à ces multinationales
pollueuses, qui font
du lobbyisme.
- Attendu de pied ferme,
le ministre de l'Environnement
s'est engagé mercredi à dévoiler
au cours des prochains jours
les détails des ententes.
BENOIT CHARETTE, ministre
de l'Environnement, Québec
- C'est-à-dire quelle est
l'autorisation, la nature de
l'autorisation qui est donnée,
mais également le degré
contamination excédentaire.
- Dans la liste des entreprises,
sept dans la Capitale-Nationale.
C'est toutefois dans les régions
du Saguenay-Lac-t-t-t-Jean
et du Nord-du-Québec que
l'on en compte le plus,
soit 11 entreprises
dans chacune d'elles.
Interrogé sur ces nouvelles
révélations, le directeur
national de la santé publiquese.
- Lorsqu'il y a des expositions
à risque pour des popioioions,
nous sommes normalement invités
à regarder ce qu'il en est
et surtout, s'il y a des
dépassements. Les directionsdeds
les régions sont mobilisées
aussi là-dessus régulièrement.
Il y a des exemples, que ce soit
dans différentes régions.
Même Québec, Montréal, tout ça,
on a ça régulièrement.
- La Fonderie Horne, c'est
une exception en soi. On n'a pas
d'écart équivalent dans
ces 89 autres dossiers-là.
- Anne Gauthier demeure
Il n'y a personne qui va mourir.
La Fonderie Horne, c'est un
enjeu.
- Anne Gauthier demeure
sceptique malgré tout.
- Le gouvernement, il ne met pas
ses culottes, puis la loi
n'est pas assez sévère,
de mon point de vue à moi.
- Le ministre de l'Environntntnt
s'est engagé à tenir des
consultations publique